[Music]
hi everyone so I'm calm I'm from Vietnam
little bit about me I am full time react
native software engineer for a company
named employment hero which is HR
platform from Australia before that I
make iOS app and build a server by
nodejs
so I'm here today to share with you guys
about tools that I'm curry working on to
serve my daily problem when I do the
coding please notice that I mentioned I
will mention a lot about react react
native Redux but if you from different
backgrounds like angular ember or view
you see tech benefit form the top so
gallant they get stuff from my tools
that I used in my current workflow so
this is tools that I use daily because I
react native developer so I new chrome
dev tools to debug a new live load as
well as react they're tuned and we redux
they're tuned to time travel and the
react hot daughter you know that tool
doesn't exist in vacuum they exist you
solve the problem
and when I say tools I mean the tools
that help us to improve our productivity
and keep our sanity thing like when we
change UI the page will immediately
update to reflect the changes or we can
easily spin point on the bug stuff like
that there's more tools like run and
webpack crucify grown-up chairs
s-sarah but is that there are tasks
runner and a bill tooled and they are
not the topic so i get started
michael of time when I work on my first
website it was a single page application
that we completely on jQuery and the
whole page with a check at the point
2010 people thought that I crazy because
no one did that except for some big guy
like Facebook Google but I did it anyway
and my first experience when I try to
debug is something like this
I knew this alert a lot when I try to
debugging like to understand what is a
synchronous thing come back and if I
look but you know it's work right we
tried to I try to to file the bug and
it's work but it's not good it's not
good and then I knew about chrome dev
tools and it really makes my life easier
so this is the chrome dev tools you can
do a lot of do a lot of stuff on this
you can set the prac ponds check the
corn-stack debug with a meaningful
meaning my code by using the source map
beside that is has many feature like
network performance timeline and let you
know about the information of your page
how I get render JavaScript and see
there's performance and of course is
expecting Dom and star tinker matter
over time but this was a problem that
whenever I change the code and it
suppressed fi to reverse the page which
for me is very tedious thing and then I
find out the
the app named live reload it's claimed
to be a supreme developer to wonderland
a happy land where the browser don't
need a refresh button so whenever you
change your file is we also refers your
web page and if you church change the
image URL or just a test
it just update immediately without fully
refreshed your whole page and for your
information react native have the world
look live reload as a viewing feature
and I'd use it every day so next let's
talk about we are kept tuned so this is
real depth in chrome attention you can
see that you can do a lot of stuff with
it you can see the hierarchy of your
react app you can treat it props just
stayed as well as the infer and listener
of your component and if you if you
redux you may not need but you know if
you if you use it there's a tool cone
without step tool which allow you do a
lot of thing list it can lock your
action in many form and you can see what
action you just be patch with what
payload and which part of your reduc
star change by on that action there's a
feature called
time travel which is a very cool one
that allow you to go backward something
like undo
like for example you have a login form
and you work and when you click the
login button the response from the
server it turns so fast then you cannot
see the loading indicator and what if
you just want to do a UI changes for
that loading indicator so just you time
travel then you can go back
like what so any point of time from the
past I will I will show you later if I
have enough of time and then we have a
library cone react hot reload
you can see on the screen is how can how
I can enable it on react native so what
it does is that is leverage the web pack
called Mattoon do loads to allow you to
treat your components without losing the
state of your apps for example if you
are walking on the pavement screen and
when you change is code I mean the
payment screen code
the app will update immediately and you
you still at the same screen but with
the newest code and you don't lose any
stay of your app and anything that you
input in the form still be there and for
me it's a big win because I don't need
to do a whole process like login pick up
the products and then go to the cart and
then checkout fielding the building
information to get on the payment screen
but they're more so let's say you are
feel developer or angular or amber there
are tools that help you to make your
life easier like future a step tool and
inspector angular every circle chair
step tool and a lot more each platform
and framework this has their own dev
tools which have developer is lease to
figure out what is the problem and and
how to fix it so the next question is
are we there yet so I mean when I say
that I mean are we happy with our our
our current workflow is there anything
that we can improve on it so the thing
about my workflow again
so I start with the mock-up like
designer give you a screen and then
based on that screen I can make react
component react native components based
on that mock-up and then I will
implement some business logic and then I
turn on my hot reload so that whenever I
change the UI called or the business
logic the app will change accordingly
without using state yeah and then when
the bug comes with just you chrome dev
tools to to figure out how you can fix
it and it's been pretty neat right but
it's not this is one thing that we can
control is data from external services
for example response of an API call like
when we when you do a to do a pray you
want to send a request to the server and
then get a respond back and then render
whatever the server sent back to you but
you do not have the power to to decide
what is a response that you want to
forget and yeah there's a there's a walk
around solution such a we can have coat
the the data or we just use the mock
server but those require code changes
and when you find yourself and ups with
you sitting back and forth between the
mouse server and the real API but how
can we
so how can we simulate the very 8 cases
like when the user login 5 time we want
to show our error message from the
server but do we want to just login 5
time to just see the error message no I
don't so I create a tools
actually it's a chrome attention and
named it reason here's what it looked
like is there the gift I will play it
right now but what you are seeing is uh
you can see that is the chrome dev tool
and the reason up here is a panel beside
of the source map and the control and on
the left hand side very dummy
Lucky's login page which allow you to
enter your name and is it is this in the
database is will redirect you to the
dashboard if not and just display the
arrow the first time I will try with the
real API so it returned you and
authorized and then I turn on the mock
and then when I click login there's a
button the green one I can click on that
and change the response to whatever I
want
so why reason why I make this chrome
attention so with reason you don't need
to have code anything and you can easily
to simulate the complex cases like
imagine that you need you have the form
and the first time the users submit that
form the server will return you repair
time our error message at the five
second but the second time it will
succeed how can you simulate that with
your current workflow I think there's no
way except you like change your code I
have caught it but with the reason you
can just type out whatever you want so
it will help you to simulate the
responses the only limitation is your
immunity date imagination I think in the
future we
and have the feature like those cases we
can name it is scenario and when we find
out there's a scenario that we haven't
handled yet we can just export it I
spawned a scenario from the reason and
then send it back to the other developer
in your team or your p.m. and say hey I
think there's a case that we didn't
handle it properly and vision will
cross-platform even with the react
native okay so he's time for life demo
okay okay here we are
okay can you see it right so this is the
example that I get from the Redux
response story so it's a very simple one
just just pull the latest news with the
keyword right here
forum graded so I will try to present
again okay very fast okay I just proved
with you that is actually fetch form
ready server and now what I gonna do is
that I will try to modify the response
from the server okay how I can do that
I will turn it on and then I will click
the refresh okay so now you see that the
whole page is in the loading state and
there's a green button that his name is
released the request with the ID of the
request and then you just keep whatever
respond that you want
okay here I copy sorry I will pass the
contents after respond sorry it's uh
there's something wrong with the
response so it doesn't highlight and all
the time okay that's right I think it
doesn't work because I miss something
no please
okay so this one should be like this
No yes Wow okay this one on so sorry
about this
I just happened because I just copy and
paste it but basically what it does is
that when whenever I click return the
mock object is will respond the data
that I just enter instead of going to
the greatest server and and fetch that
how can we fix it
can you have one minute that I could lie
to fix it it's very cool and I really
want to share with you
I are gonna do is I just checked the sin
tag because it's a JSON so if it's not
in the correct format as we crash the
app okay a lot of okay so it's there's a
lot of you know it should be like
instead of being like this is to be like
double collect this and because of the
editor so we cannot change
Oh actually we can yeah that feature
okay so I will save this one for if you
have if you want to see it just comes to
me after this talk and we will I will
show you this demo because a pretty sure
that when I click return is not gonna
work so you have to option whether you
want to return the mock object or you
can forward it forwards mean that it
will fetch the real API instead of
return your mouth later you have time
for for me to fix it yeah I think a
minute we have I kind of computers now
about the result okay I will try to do a
fast way I can I just want to bring out
hello jazz conference give me one minute
if it's not that I just give up
okay so I will go to just one double
click on that okay
copy this vodka we crazy okay yeah we
trying to modify this a little bit
just hold on okay here okay
hi
praise to the timeouts 10 second I
almost there okay got it
so then we turn on the mark again and we
do the refresh and there's a button here
I'll pass pass he yep it's as I did this
mean that is correct
wish me luck
not okay but I will show you later I
promise okay that back sooo you can
check the code at this link so it's a
Hong Kong to art fusion and with that I
would like to thank you
[Applause]
you